we begin with an urgent plea on gun
control from president biden in a rare
prime time address from the white house
using candles as a backdrop the
president urged congress to act to
finally reform gun laws after a series
of mass shootings in buffalo uvalde
tulsa and dozens of other communities
the imagery of crisis violence and grief
has become all too familiar in american
life nancy cordes joins us from the
white house nancy good morning
good morning nate this may have been the
most emphatic speech this president has
delivered when it comes to guns it's an
issue he's been reluctant to dwell on
until now because the chances of passing
anything are just so slim but that was
before 19 third and fourth graders were
gunned down in texas using the kind of
weapon that used to be banned
let us finally do something after a
month of mass shootings in uvalde
buffalo tulsa and more president biden
pleaded with republicans to support new
gun control laws too many other everyday
places that have become killing fields
battlefields here in america his
ambitious wish list includes a ban on
high-capacity magazines universal
background checks new safe storage laws
and red flag laws and a return to the
assault weapons ban that he helped to
pass in 1994. if we can't ban assault
weapons then we should raise the aids to
purchase them from 18 to 21. he pointed
to studies that show mass shooting
deaths tripled after congress left the
assault weapons ban lapse in 2004 the
second amendment like all other rights
is not absolute this isn't about taking
to anyone's rights
it's about protecting children but in
the house the battle lines haven't
changed this is on our watch
where is the outrage how dare you
you think we don't have hearts house
democrats and republicans debated a
major package of gun laws thursday for
nearly 10 hours we are paying
for this deadly culture with the lives
of the american people this bill would
not stop the terrible events it wouldn't
harden schools but it will sure take
away the rights
of the american people who follow the
law in the senate a bipartisan group
says it's making progress on measures to
address red flag laws school safety and
mental illness every day that goes by we
get closer to an agreement not further
away
but that agreement if it comes together
will not include some of these major gun
safety measures that the president is
calling for like raising the purchasing
age for assault weapons from 18 to 21.
some states however are moving ahead on
their own just yesterday new york
state's legislature passed a bill that
would do just that and it now heads to
the governor's desk tony
as with so much else else in this
country it heads to the states and then
maybe the courts nancy thank you very
much we appreciate it